the next round of roast battles coming
up so we wanted to remind you why you
like watching comics tear into each
other in the first place so we decided
to compile the 10 best burns in the last
two seasons enjoy Tony's the only time
you've ever made a wet is when you
drowned a bag of cats the heat on that
burn can melt heart and it did you know
bring that costume back within an hour I
mean you look like you worked at
Hogwarts which is what girls get when
they give no but I have Jimmy
they're both ugly for America to
recognize Mike come to Rose bottle to
see comics tear into each other but you
stay for the incisive political
commentary you know what that one
brought awareness to a very important
issue also which is that joke Armenian
Genocide what's so worried about the if
Michael Moore got gangbanged by Juggalos
I'm just glad Abe Lincoln was alive to
hear that hasn't liked more Bing
gangbanged by Juggalos you know what I
think he's doing a documentary about I
didn't know much about Olivia so I went
to her website which is called Olivia is
funny calm I know
if she can call our website Olivia's
funny comm I can call mine Todd is
really tall and has a full head of hair
calm Todd so easy to Rose that he
couldn't resist doing it to himself at
the end there Todd's been roasting me my
entire career so chili there's 70
people at the bottom of it thinking
they're gonna die oh man I miss Ralphie
Ralphie May
hats off to you buddy roast in peace see
kids the key to a good roast joke is
specificity who else by Anna couldn't
think of a mtv2 better anybody who's
ever watched the real joke is the idea
that anyone would date her actually
there was so much sexual tension or in
that battle they were banging in the
greenroom after Matt's alive like the
food at my work he's about to get served
by a Mexican that's never eaten us out
of a country club so who knows he even
got that joke you're right probably
didn't even get it you know people are
asking me tonight if I'm gonna put Sarah
in her place she's a 38 year old woman
in comedy there isn't one Hockman a big
shout out to all the Roasters for not
crying on stage seriously those were
harsh and the Bellas have set a pretty
high bar but we promised season three
will bring even more
you